you have a terrific sense of humor and
at one of the most critical points of
your life and this is in the in your
book and it's also depicted in the film
was when you first woke up in the
hospital after the bombing and you knew
what had happened to you and you knew
that you had lost your legs the first
thing you did was make a joke yeah what
was what was that what was decision well
first I wrote as Aaron okay that I went
to watch my girlfriend who is now my
baby mama yeah and after I found out she
was okay I saw the look on my friends
face and he was looking sad so I was
like all right I got a mess with them so
I wrote lieutenant dan down on the piece
of paper because he was trying to
explain to me that I didn't have my legs
haha I know yeah yeah you and you were
trying to sort of put him at ease you
know there's no sugar coating in your
book or in the film and I think that's
really admirable this is an incredible
shock to go through this experience and
you had a hard time adjusting and you
say that you were drinking too much
afterwards yeah I was drinking a ton I
mean you know how Boston is you go out
and next thing you know I have five
shots in front of me and three beers
people of course you know what you had
been through when everyone was like hey
man do a shot with me you know and and
it got out of hand yeah it got really
got it way out of hand
but you know I you saw this depicted I'm
told that when you saw that depicted in
the film it really had a strong effect
on you yeah it did I haven't drank in 15
months so when I really when I saw the
film I was really kind of proud of
myself that I've come a long way since
15 months and you know I went back to
school full-time and you know I'm just
spending you know the all my free time
with my daughter now so how old is your
daughter how old is he gonna
I won't give honest she's two years old
right three years old you've actually
been quoted as saying you feel that
you're better off today than you were
before the bombing I think you feel that
that's true yeah some days if those feel
like that I mean I'm sitting next to
Conan right now and Andy that's sweet
that's very sweet but set that bar a
little higher but but if I think in
terms of probably just your perspective
on life maybe your ass oh yeah my life
is a lot richer and those in that sense
you know I just I've met some great
people that have influenced me to you
know be the best person I can be and
also it's you know I challenged myself
and you know now Jake challenges me and
he's you know he's a crazy person
yes yeah but he's a wonderful guy - it's
amazing he's a great friend and he's
challenging me everyday you know now he
wants me to run and he said you got to
run I don't like all right I you don't
have to listen to him you know I do want
to explain to people something that that
I hadn't even realized before you came
here today which is you lost your legs
above the knee and and that when people
lose their legs below the knee it's much
easier that for them to get prosthetics
and to adapt and it is many times harder
if it's above the knee because you have
to learn so many things over again is
that right yeah it's um well yeah you're
kind of depending on this knee mechanism
which is you know beautiful it's like
these are Auto bakit German company
makes them called all the balk and you
know there's micro processors bluetooth
and actually to drive I this go on the
Bluetooth and I could walk my leg at an
angle and I can drive any car amazing
and this has gotten you which i think is
fascinating into wanting to work on
prosthetics and help and engineer them
and you've decided you went back to
school and you've been working on that
is that right
yeah yeah and so would you like to
actually be someone who designs these
would you like to be doing that for a
living I would love that
no it would be like a great guinea pig
too because I can this try anything that
design right so you can come in the next
day and go like these legs suck this is
all over I got him up to 85 miles an
hour and they quit on me yeah
did you is it true that you put you
tried you were messing around because
you're a pretty ingenious guy you were
messing around you figured out a way to
put a solar charger on your prosthetic
leg is that right it was a simple very
simple sure yeah not to me well I just
got it this inverter and I hooked up
like right this mobile solar panel and I
got some good sunlight and they were
charging my legs right whoa that's
amazing so you got to move out of
Massachusetts then that's a good move so
yeah there's no solar power there
you